schon heute könnten wir mit
herkömmlichen autos komplett
klimaneutral fahren sondern es möglich
machen das heißt benzin das mittels
elektrizität aus wasser und co2 gewonnen
wird ist das die lösung um den
klimawandel aufzuhalten es gibt einen
haken klick zum sieg hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nicht herzlich willkommen
es könnte alles so einfach sein mittels
strom aus wasser per elektrolyse
wasserstoff gewinnen und co2 aus der
atmosphäre filtern und fertig ist der
klimaneutrale treibstoff wenn der strom
aus regenerativen energien kommt und e
views also electric tools haben einen
riesigen vorteil es werden keine lage
sollen benötigt keine elektroautos und
die alten fahrzeuge können weiter
benutzt werden
statt millionen neue elektrofahrzeuge zu
verkaufen gegen das ohne eine solche
riesige investition aber warum kann man
diese treibstoffe noch nicht kaufen und
warum kommen sie in der diskussion über
den klimawandel praktisch nicht vor
im gegenteil nahezu alle
umweltschutzorganisationen verdammen sie
es ist die effizienz ein elektro auto
verbraucht je nach größe etwa 15
kilowattstunden auf 100 kilometer schon
mal mit wasserstoffbetriebenen
brennstoffzellen fahrzeugen sinkt die
effizienz deutlich der wasserstoff muss
erst per elektrolyse also mit
elektrischen strom aus wasser gewonnen
werden das ist mit verlusten behaftet
ein wasserstoffauto verbraucht deshalb
das doppelte eines elektroautos rund 30
kilowattstunden auf 100 kilometer und
beim wird es nahezu desaströs bei der
produktion und im motor entstehen
verluste die den verbrauch auf mehr als
100 kilowattstunden schnellen lassen das
7 fache eines elektroautos letztendlich
wahnsinn und der grund für die große
ablehnung aber mit was sollen flugzeuge
und schiffe angetrieben werden hier
könnten hybridantriebe mittels die
lösung sein beim flugzeug könnten
mittels angetriebene düsen den vortrieb
beim staat leisten wozu heute elektrisch
angetriebene düsen einfach nicht in der
lage wären während des langstreckenflugs
könnte das flugzeug elektrisch auf
reisegeschwindigkeit gehalten wäre
die luft ist dünn in der reiseflughöhe
und damit der luftwiderstand gering und
auch bei schiffen könnte das die lösung
sein bevor batterien mit höherer
energiedichte zur verfügung stehen und
die großen ölkonzerne arbeiten deshalb
an der produktion solcher treibstoffe
sie haben schließt sich die expertise
für brennstoffe shell hat gerade mit dem
bau einer elektrolyse anlage in
nordrhein westfalen begonnen die
lufthansa hat in schleswig holstein mit
der produktion von klimaneutralem
kerosin begonnen der flughafen rotterdam
arbeitet an der entwicklung einer fabrik
für evs und audi hat sich mit
energieversorgern und ölkonzernen
zusammengetan um evans zu produzieren
allerdings bleibt die kritik greenpeace
hält den weg generell für falsch
allerdings gibt es eine nische de für
uns sehr interessant machen
überschüssiger strom an einem
windreichen tagen müssen zahlreiche
windkraft anlagen vom netz genommen
werden ihr strom ist einfach zu viel und
wird nicht gebraucht an einem solchen
tag könnte diese energie genutzt werden
um e plus zu produzieren damit könnte
überschüssiger strom gespeichert werden
und klimaneutralen verbrennungsmotoren
verbrannt werden oder dittmeyer ist
professor am karlsruher institut für
technologie kit
er hatte die idee für container große
produktionsanlagen sie können einfach
neben windräder gestellt werden und
produzieren dann treibstoff wenn zu viel
wind weht sein kollege timo bald gebaut
sie mit seiner firma innerer tag und man
kann sie jetzt schon kaufen und das ist
noch nicht alles
noch mehr infos zum thema gibt es auf
klicks um nature dem neuen kanal mit
videos zur natur und umwelt anklicken da
anschauen und auf jeden fall abonnieren
ich freue mich mit euch dort etwas gegen
den klimawandel und für eine bessere
umwelt zu tun bis dann bleibt dran